hi there
hi
how are you doing i'm good how are you
christina i am doing very well i
appreciate you talking to me about this
first of all congrats on such an
incredible performance in this i can't
imagine this was easy to go through
um i had it you know i had it pretty
easy i'm just playing pretend
yeah
well when this whole project came your
way what were you most excited about
getting to do and what most scared you
about it
um i think
my answer for both of those is actually
the same i think i was the most excited
to have the opportunity to play a mom
because
i'm certainly not a mother and then i
was also most uh and then just seemed
like a real challenge and i i never had
an opportunity to to do that um and then
i was also the
um
most scared to do it
you took on this real life story and you
did so with your own mother so yeah what
are the advantages of acting and having
to emotionally really essentially bury
your soul alongside your mother and what
are the challenges of doing that was
there ever a moment you were glad to
have her there
the whole time i was glad yeah no i was
my idea i was so excited about it i am
i i was up in canada quarantining and
the role of my mom was still open and it
dawned on me that i've always wanted to
work with my mom
um and then i was like whoa this is it
this this my mom's gotta do this and i
called margot robbie and she loved the
idea and then you know everyone was on
board and really excited about it and
and then i was just like crossing my
fingers hoping my mom would want to do
it and i lucked out she wanted to do it
so then she came up to canada and it was
it was a real dream getting to work with
her i mean
it was
one of the more surreal experiences of
my life and you know and across the
board like there's there's the comfort
of having your mom in the same place
when you're in the middle of a pandemic
and you're away from home for nine
months and then there's also just the
well then there's my mom's whole body of
work which i'm in complete of and
couldn't look up to her more and then
um
there's this thing where you walk into
the room and your mom is playing your
mom and that like
definitely shifts the situation it's
like the biggest cheat i've ever
managed to pull off
it's one thing to know her body of work
but what impressed you about her as a
scene partner and actually you know
playing those moments with her
she's the best i mean
it seems like it's the easiest thing in
the world for her and um she
she's so giving and cool and uh
i mean
yeah i
i don't even
yeah yeah
there are so many things that are
so infuriating about everything that
your character has to go through
just to get by on the day-to-day basis
what most infuriated you about all of
that
um
that's a good question um
i guess
i guess you know
just how quite literally impossible it
all is um
the
the scenes that i have when you know
we're talking about like trying to
um
you know to even get get food stamps or
get housing or anything like these like
the amount of
of hoops that you have to jump through
in order to even qualify are outrageous
and then it's like winning the lottery
to actually be chosen to
to
have this thing that is not even so
great to begin with um
it's just the amount of work that she
has to go through is really
wild
yeah
i mean because of all of that how do you
feel about where things end up for her
were you
it really leaves on a hopeful note even
though we don't know exactly what will
happen to her in the future you do have
a sense of hope for her so how did you
feel about the ending of all of this
um
i thought it was a pretty beautiful
ending um
i i believe in alex so much i mean
i don't know who wouldn't she's
so incredibly strong and ambitious and
and kind and i think um
i have no i have no doubt that that
she'll keep fighting but at the same
time i think that it's uh
while alex was able to persevere and
navigate these
really challenging circumstances the
truth of the matter is that so many
people in the same situation
don't have the same luck um
and and
and despite the fact that she is
incredibly
um driven and smart it also required
luck because these circumstances are so
grave
you've done projects from the leftovers
to fosse verdon to this that are very
complex and complicated material have
you ever wished more comedy would come
your way do you all the [ __ ] time
like do you do you relish you know
putting yourself through an emotional
roller coaster you know christina like i
think you should talk to a lot more
people about this because
i am like uh where is it i yeah no i
i don't i don't get those parts i try
really hard no one wants me to be in
those movies um i so badly i so badly
want that but um i'm just not funny
enough i guess you know
i'm the sad girl
i don't know why
do you know what's next for you do you
are you working on something now do you
know what the next project is
um yeah i just finished a little indie
here in new york that was really fun it
was called sanctuary um zach wiggin
directed it and it was me and chris
abbott and then um
it was awesome
and then i'm i'm about to go to panama
um to work on this claire denis movie
i'm excited about
with taran etcherton called stars at
noon so that'll keep me busy for a
minute
and sanctuary you played a dominatrix
right i did yeah but like
that lends itself to a connotation that
makes it seem like a lot more sexy than
it really is in reality it's not like s
m or anything it's
it's like psycho psychological
domineering um but it was so fun
yeah it certainly seems like a big
comparison with this character yeah it's
lighter it's certainly lighter than this
it's not communic or i guess there's
comedic elements but it's not like
you know it's still kind of heavy i
don't know
what did you enjoy most about the bond
that you formed with your young co-star
because that mother-daughter
relationship that you guys have is just
so so purely beautiful thank you it's
her birthday today happy birthday riley
um
so uh no riley and i got super super
close because
i mean as you can imagine no
four-year-old should really be working
so i had to make sure it didn't feel
like work
um and so i basically just became her
person on set and i'd carry her around
and have you know crayons and
snacks she's vegan so i would have all
kinds of like healthy things and we'd
play and i hung out with her every
sunday just to try to make it so that i
didn't like only seem like
the person who was telling her to do
things because you know oftentimes if
you put if there's like out of all you
know if you see a four-year-old sitting
in a car seat that means that she had to
do it at least 10 times which means that
i you know i had to buckle her in 10
times and no four-year-old wants to do
that um so i'd have to come up with all
kinds of fun games in order to keep it
light and like an exciting thing to get
in that car again um but but she's great
and i really i
i've always appreciated the crew but it
wasn't until this experience that i
really really connected with
with the crew in such a massive way um
because you know the directors are
changing and now it's nine months and
the cinematographers are changing in and
out but the one thing that's constant is
the crew and so
um
you know they'd see me struggling to get
riley to do things and it became a
really massive group effort like if
she's supposed to be asleep i'd be like
okay let's see if you can trick ian
who's like the camera operator and see
if
he can be convinced that you're asleep
so then you know riley pretends to be
asleep when we go up to ian i'm like was
she asleep or was she pretending and
then ian's like she had to be asleep and
then we'd do the same thing to you know
scott the props guy or misha the
tad and and um and it just became this
like joint effort to make every day
happen um and and
it was really amazing it's like it's
it's amazing to have all these people
make such a beautiful game of high
stakes pretend in any circumstance but
in the context of uh pandemic you know
when everyone's wearing masks and
they're risking their health just to to
make something it really takes your
breath away well thank you so much for
talking about it you're fantastic i'm
sorry for that really long answer
thank you so much
you